[Music]
please welcome
jessica intermel
[Music]
well hello minnesota
i can't tell you how much of an honor it
is to be here with you today
my name is jessica intermil and i am a
minnesotan
with a pre-existing condition we have
all heard all year how this is the most
consequential election
of our lifetime and maybe in history
it's not an exaggeration
the very future of our democracy and the
health and well-being of our communities
are on the ballot and i know that
because
i live that in 2012 when i was seven
months pregnant
i was diagnosed with rheumatoid
arthritis
now rheumatoid arthritis is a vicious
disease
where a body attacks itself through its
own immune system
so my body started attacking my joints
and eating holes
into my bones it's extraordinarily
painful
sometimes just turning a key in a lock
can feel like my knuckles will just
burst open
but there is no cure but i did find a
medication
the problem is that medication costs 54
000 per year every year
for the rest of my life now before the
affordable care act was signed into law
my medication would have bankrupted me
my pregnancy itself could have been
considered a pre-existing condition
but the aca kept me and my family afloat
for eight years
[Music]
joe biden helped pass that aca
now
[Music]
20 million more americans
have insurance now than 10 years ago joe
biden
fought for millions like me who have
pre-existing conditions and when i tell
you that the stakes of this election are
life and death
i'm speaking from personal experience
and yes senator klobuchar i
do take this personally
because donald
because donald trump wants to repeal the
affordable care act
he said that he's at the supreme court
right now
asking them to strike down that law
but if that happens if i lose my
insurance
then i will get that 54 000
bill i can't afford that
i'm here to tell you that if we elect
joe biden we'll have an
ally in the white house instead of an
adversary
[Music]
he'll make health care available to more
americans than
ever before instead of repealing the
affordable care act
he'll build on it he'll add a public
auction
to expand coverage and he'll lower
prescription drug and other health costs
now minnesotans are already voting in
record numbers
but the job isn't done yet
with so much at stake we cannot afford
to be complacent
we can't relax i can't
relax until we're certain that every
minnesotan has done their part
and cast their ballots for joe biden and
kamala harris
[Music]
so here's what i need you to do if you
haven't voted yet go
do it today go to iwillvote.com mn
to find an early voting site near you
and if you have an absentee ballot that
you haven't mailed in yet
take it in person as soon as possible
to a drop-off location
if we keep up the work for the next four
days
we will elect joe biden
so with that it is my distinct honor
to introduce the man himself the next
president of the united states of
america
joe biden
[Applause]
[Music]
hello minnesota
jessica thank you for being here and for
sharing your story
unfortunately the story of so many other
americans they have stories like you're
faced with health problems fighting for
their lives
and forced to think not only about
facing the battle
but about how they can afford the
treatment
while insurance companies come
and in at the most vulnerable moments
for you and your family members i
remember when my son beau
was lying in the hospital after he came
home from
iraq after a year he had stage four
glioblastoma they told him not whether
he
was going to live but just how long
would he live
as he lay there fighting for his life
fighting to hang on i thought to myself
what would it be like
if it is suffering my insurance company
here's the insurance company is able to
come in and say you've run out of
coverage
time's up you're on your own
well folks it's a question no one should
have to face in america
that's why i fought so hard and why
obamacare was such a big thing
it's unconscionable
[Music]
it's uncomfortable that donald trump
from the day he got elected till right
now he's fighting in court
to rip that peace of mind away from tens
of millions of americans
but we're not going to let him do it
we're never going back to those days
and you're going to vote we're going to
win for you
jessica and your family and i promise
you
i will protect your family as if it were
my own
[Music]
i want to thank all of all the speakers
you heard earlier
your governor tim is great who's leading
minnesota
with decency and integrity and one of
the outstanding
members of congress ben mccollum let's
send her back
to the house of representatives we need
her badly
and your incredible junior senator tina
smith who i got to speak a little bit
back here
she's got to go back and look
let's win back the minnesota state
senate
while we're at it
[Music]
one of the nation's finest leaders and a
dear friend i've been honored to stand
alongside
and fight together for the soul of this
nation for a long time
senator a.b globalcar amy i love you
thank you
thank you yesterday in florida
i had a chance to spend a little more
time with another minnesota icon
carl anthony towns you gotta hurt him
where he can play man you all know him
as the heart and soul of the
timberwolves
but he's also the a son who like many
other americans
lost his mom to covert 19
a couple months ago for all those sons
and daughters
those parents siblings husbands and
wives
facing empty chairs and dining room
tables
have empty holes in their hearts all
those who reach over at night
implicitly just by instinct to say
goodnight
to their husband or wife they deserve so
much better
these guys are not very polite but
they're like trump
but look they're gonna be okay we're
gonna take care of them as well
we need to come together you need to
fight for all these folks
we have four days left to get it done
four days
and millions of americans are already
voting millions more will vote
by tuesday and i believe when you use
your power the power to vote
will change the course of this country
in the course of history
right here in minnesota with all of you
in the final days
keep that sense of empowerment keep an
important empowerment with you that
sense of optimism
what we can overcome now look there's a
reason they don't want to hear me
because they know the president doesn't
say anything
so they're not used to not hearing
anything
well i know it's hard folks i know it's
hard more than
228 i believe it is now thousand
americans have died because of coca-19
nearly 2 500 here
in minnesota gone we had nine million
new cases nationwide
millions of americans are out of work on
the edge
they can't see any light they don't know
where it's going
and donald trump he's simply given up
over the weekend white house counsel
chief of staff
he said the following we're not going to
control the pandemic
at the debate last week donald trump
turned to me and said we're rounding the
corner
it's going away we're learning to live
with it
but as i told him no he's asking us to
learn
to die with it we're not going to
and did you hear what he said today
what he said today on the trail he said
that our doctors
our doctors are first responders
over a thousand lost their lives are
putting their lives on the line busting
their necks
making up he said but they're making up
deaths
from covert because they get more money
the president of the united states is
accusing the medical profession
of making up cover deaths so they make
more money
doctors and nurses go to work every day
to save lives
they do their jobs donald trump just
started to stop
attacking them and do his job
[Music]
[Applause]
folks this is the same man
who weeks ago when he was told we're
losing a thousand lives a day
you remember what he said he said it is
what it is
that's thoughtful well it is what it is
because
he is who he is
donald trump has waved the white flag
and surrendered to this virus
but the american people don't give up
they don't cower
neither why remember when he told
when he did that interview and he told
bob woodward
that he knew about the virus how deadly
it was the end of january
but he didn't tell anybody he didn't
even tell those folks
he didn't tell anybody and at woodward
asked him why
and on tape he said because he didn't
want to panic the american people
the american people don't panic donald
trump
panics
[Music]
and unlike donald trump we will not
surrender to this virus
look president trump is spreading
division and discord
he thinks that he can divide us
we won't notice his failures that's what
it's all about
that's why he shamelessly equates somali
refugees
folks seeking a better life in america
contributing to this state in our
country
with terrorists as he did last night
we need a president who bring us
together
not pull us apart i'll deal with this
pandemic responsibly
bringing the country together around
testing
tracing asking it's estimated
by the leading doctors in this country
that if we just wore
mass for the next few months we'd save
over a hundred
thousand lives of over two hundred
thousand lives they expect to lose
dr fauci call
for a mass mandate last week
this isn't a political statement like
those ugly folks over there
beeping the horde this is a patriotic
duty for god's sake
look in his own words
as i said the president knew back in
january how extremely dangerous and
communicable
this disease was and i told you he went
on and he made that tape
he said it was disease was easily able
to spread
but he did nothing he did nothing at all
look folks
american people are people are tough
and instead of talking and politicizing
the vaccine
he should be planning for a safe
equitable and free distribution of a
vaccine
when it comes next year
[Music]
this guy refuses to provide schools and
small businesses
the resources and the national standards
open safely
the house of representatives already
passed the money
to allow schools to open safely
businesses open safely
to make sure people are paid ladies and
gentlemen
we'll bring republican democrats
together to deliver economic relief
for working families schools and
businesses
as i said before i'm not going to shut
down the economy
i'm going to shut down the virus
donald trump inherited a strong economy
that barack and i gave him
but guess what like everything else he
inherited he squandered it
like everything he's inherited but we
can build back and we can build back
better
with an economy that rewards work not
wealth
we can do it without raising taxes on
the middle class and working families
i promise you you have my word if you
make less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year you
won't pay a penny more in taxes
but i tell you what for the first time
in a long time
the wealthiest and biggest corporations
are going to start paying their fair
share
91 out of a fortune 500 companies paid
zero in taxes last year
why why should a firefighter an educator
and that guy blowing that horn
why should he pay why should a nurse pay
higher tax rates
than a super wealthy why should you pay
more taxes
than donald trump pays
he's exploited every loophole in tax
code
he's run a shell game to avoid paying
taxes if you notice
i've released 22 years of my tax returns
he's not released
one single year what's he hiding
what's the corruption according to trump
the reason why i only paid 750 dollars
is because he's smart
well what does that make the rest of us
to pay our fair share mr president
we're going to deliver tax relief for
working families in the middle class
help you buy your first home pay for
health care premiums
or child care or care for your aging
parents
or be able to actually actually pay for
school
trump got a supreme court justice first
time it's ever happened and
while elections already started for one
reason
he's determined to do what he's been
trying to do for four years
destroy the affordable care act if they
get their way
100 million americans will lose
protections for preexisting conditions
complications with code with 19 will be
the next pre-existing condition
allowing insurers to jack up your
premiums or deny your coverage
and women will again be able to be
charged
more for the same health care as a man
just because they're a woman
donald trump thinks health care is a
privilege i think
it's your right
[Music]
and broke it out and vote we'll not only
restore obamacare we'll strengthen it
and build on it
so you can keep your private insurance
if that's what you like
or choose a medicare-like option the
public option
will increase subsidies lower your
premiums than deductibles
out-of-pocket spending reduce
prescription costs by
60 by allowing medicare to negotiate
with drug prices
we're going to keep the protections for
people with pre-existing conditions
and will protect social security
medicare
meanwhile the social security actuary
said
that if donald trump donald trump said
elect me again and i'm going to change
social security
the actuary said if the changes he puts
in place
occur the social security bankrupt
in 23 2023
so go home and tell your parents your
grandparents
just what trump's about to do i'll
protect social security
medicare and medicaid but folks
nothing's worse that this president has
done than the way he spoke about those
who served in uniform
he called them losers and suckers
my son beau
gave up the attorney general's seat in
the united state of delaware
to volunteer to go to iraq for a year
he won the bronze star the conspicuous
service medal
he wasn't a loser or sucker he was a
patriot
so many of you as well no wonder the six
generals who work directly for the trump
administration have left
and they say he does not deserve to be
the commander-in-chief of the united
states
that's never happened to any president
before
and that's why special operations
commander stanley
general stanley mcchrystal navy seal
commander admiral craven
along with 24 stars endorsed me
saying they support me to be the next
commander-in-chief because they trust me
and that's why the military times
reported that more troops will vote for
biden than trump
that's why we have to support the
military they're the backbone of the
country
so let them vote and let's vote for them
and while donald trump fails to condemn
white supremacy
we can deliver on racial justice the
season of protest has broken out across
the nation
because of life and dignity of george
floyd sensibly killed seven miles from
here and so many others that mattered
protesting and burning and looting is
not
protesting it's violence clear and
simple and will not be tolerated
but these protests are a cry for justice
the names of george florida taylor jacob
blake
will not soon be forgotten not by me not
by us not by this country
because true justice is also economic
justice
access to schooling housing access to
capital
good paying jobs and financial stability
giving families of color a real shot to
own a home
start a small business send a child to
college debt-free so they can build
wealth
and pass down opportunity through the
generations like the rest of us have
we have to vote to ensure the full
promise of this country for everyone
and finally we have to vote to meet the
challenge of the climate crisis
the west is on fire losing more forest
than the total land of connecticut and
rhode island
combined the midwest is flooding
here in minnesota extreme weather occurs
incurs
big costs for your infrastructure
increased flooding in the mississippi
watershed is shut down port facilities
here and in saint paul
donald trump thinks it's all a hoax he's
a
he sure is a stable genius
he says the wind power causes cancer
i say creates jobs minnesota jobs
we can combine we can combat climate
change
with american ingenuity manufacturing
building more resilient nation creating
millions of new high-paying jobs we can
change the path we're on
nothing's beyond our capacity so honk
your heart if you want america to lead
again
[Music]
honk your horn if you want americans to
trust each other again
honk your heart if you want to have
civility again
[Music]
and hark your heart if you want america
to be
united again
we could not afford four more years of
donald trump
in 2008 and 12 you've placed your trust
in me and barack obama and each day
we're in office we work
for you and the entire community i'll do
it again in 2020.
my campaign is a broad coalition of
democrats
republicans independents democrat
republican office holders i'm running as
a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work as hard for those who don't
support me as those who do
because that's the job of a president
it's the duty of care for everyone
and you too have a sacred duty the duty
to vote it matters
minnesota matters so on the final days
stay empowered stay optimistic stay
united
make a plan to vote help get out the
vote
as amy said go to iowavote.com
mn yesterday the federal appeals court
forced the last minute change in the
rules absentee ballots
had to receive by tuesday so if you want
your voice to be heard drop off your
ballot
don't put in the mail or vote safely in
person
any day up through election day but
you've got to get it done
and make sure everyone you know votes as
well
so they'll not be able to stop us
despite
trump's efforts recent press article
points out
that quote never before in modern
presidential politics
i'm quoting now never before in modern
presidential politics
has a candidate been so reliant on
wide-scale efforts
to repress the votes as trump's end of
quote
we will not be silenced over 85 million
of
people have already voted 85 million
[Music]
they've had enough look
i'll never forget the words president
kennedy said when he promised to send us
to the moon
he said we're doing it because we in
america we
refuse to postpone
i refuse to postpone the work america
must do
there's nothing beyond our capacity
there's no limit to america including
guys like that
the only thing that can tear america
apart is america itself
that's exactly what donald trump has
been doing from the beginning
divide america fitting americans against
one another
based on race ethnicity national origin
that's wrong that's not who we are
everybody knows who donald trump is
let's keep showing them who we are
[Music]
we choose hope over fear
we choose unity over division
science over fiction and yes we choose
truth over lies
so it's time to stand up take back our
democracy
we can do this we're so much better than
this
we can be who we are at our best the
united
states of america god bless you all
and may god protect our troops thank you
thank you thank you
thank you thanks appreciate it
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
let's go
oh
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
that's so crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's
[Music]